you know why I'm here you saw the
trailer too there's a new trailer for
Christopher Nolan's interstellar Grantha
this is the second trailer there was a
trailer before I didn't do a video on it
people were like you got to do a video
on it and I was like what would I say
straight up the video would have been
like a trailer for a new Christopher
Nolan movie it has Matthew McConaughey
in it and a rocket goes into space done
today with a new bat flick Batsuit
picture people are like you got to do a
video on it I'm like what what here's
what it would be picture of Ben Affleck
in the Batsuit it looks like it's based
on the Dark Knight Returns just like we
thought it would be looks pretty neat
but this does not change the fact that
the movie looks over packed with Heroes
that are completely shoehorned into the
movie done but this new interstellar
trailer yeah there's enough to talk
about here your eyes really I mean it's
a Christopher Nolan trailer I like his
trailers because they don't give too
much away we know about as much about
interstellar at this point as we did
inception with the trailer that came out
seven months before it came out remember
that we were like I think it's about
dreams not sure about dreams this one
it's about interstellar travel is that
all it's about probably not what we
gather is that earth is dying we're all
out of food we need resources and now we
have the ability to do interstellar
travel Matthew McConaughey is this
engineer we don't need engineers here on
earth but our guests they're good in
space and so he goes to interstellar
travel that either find resources or
inhabit a planet I don't know let me see
him go around that thing I thought it
was a planet at first I thought it was a
planet because you can see it then I was
like is it a black hole I mean black
hole as I understand it would look like
that because black holes suck in light
you don't see black holes but this one
you see but it looks like some sort of
space bubbles so I'm like is it a vortex
is it a wormhole doesn't matter point is
is something that you use for
interstellar travel at that point is
that all it is is it just about people
going and trying to find a planet sci-fi
writers and directors have shown us once
you deal with interstellar travel
possibilities are endless because you're
bending space at that point once you've
been space you've been time when you
bend time do you bend reality how far
does it go with Nolan referencing
inception again we knew it was about
dreams when it came out but we didn't
know it was about dreams within dreams
within dreams and in planning an idea
into someone's head that they thought
was their own I feel like interstellar
travel is just the surface-level thing
for the movie something tells me it is
among a deep of plot yeah I'm calling it
right now they get marooned on this
really lush planet but you find out it's
earth way in the past when they're Adam
and Eve too obvious they probably do
obvious what really sells this movie is
the faith in the director the faith in
no one if you just saw this trailer and
it wasn't directed by Nolan you'd be
like it looks interesting I'm interested
to see the movie the fact that it's an
olan movie we're all jacked up for it
because we're like I'm waiting for him
to make a movie yeah Dark Knight
Rises haters now that's your opportunity
cuz Christopher Nolan's like Michael
Crichton you know Michael Crichton would
write a book about something it's
ultimately fringe science related but he
would research this out of it so
when you read it you're like it feels
possible but Nolan did for inception
with dreams I feel like that's what no
one's gonna do with this movie he's
gonna research the out of
space-time and interstellar travel and
theory of relativity so by the end we
get this movie where we're like probably
I guess yes so could just be about
interstellar travel and trying to find
resources out there in space it could be
about bending space or time or space
time it could be about inner dimensions
or a multiverse it could be the
prequel the Firefly for all I know who
knows sounds like it could be actually
having to go out there and find another
solar system yeah if China and America
have formed some super government in
this movie you heard it here first
so the interstellar trailer have you
seen it what did you think about it what
do you think it's about I love the fact
that I can ask that in a trailer because
no one really knows which gets bloggers
blogging and vloggers vlogging and
reviewers reviewing which is shows it's
pretty smart to do that studios
take note make trailers like this more
often
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]